I have a clip for you today of right-wing
Pundit Ben Shapiro, which may be his dumbest
ever, and I know that that is saying a lot.
Shapiro is known for employing a technique
of speaking quickly and confidently, which
to some people gives the idea that he knows
what he's talking about, but he often says
really silly things. Quick Reminder, here
he is talking with me about gun control when
I interviewed him a few years ago and it didn't
really take that much to get him a visibly
confused. So it's a very simple argument from
my point of view, and that is that people,
if they have the right to bear arms in order
to prevent tyranny, then that that goes for
arms to prevents it.
That goes to the the the ultimate limit of
that is the arms necessary to prevent. Basically,
you can own any arm that is necessary to necessary
rather than to, to prevent tyranny. Anyway,
make sure you check out that entire interview,
but let's talk about Ben's latest comment.
The latest comment is America has already
apologized for slavery. The civil war was
a national apology for Slavery 1619 as folks
are calling it as a massive retelling of the
American story with African Americans appropriately
at its center. It is the kind of retelling
that continues putting the calls for reparations
in the proper context and makes the absence
of a national apology. All the more galling.
So in other words, it backs Jonathan Capehart
agenda. There was a national apology for slavery.
It was called the civil war war. 700,000 Americans
died, so that that seems to have been kind
of important in American history.
This may be the dumbest thing he said. There
is no interpretation in which this makes sense.
There was a national apology for slavery called
the civil war were 700,000 Americans died.
The civil war was not an apology for slavery.
The civil war was only necessary because half
the country was willing to die to keep slavery.
Who apologized? Someone who does the fighting
to keep slavery is not apologizing for slavery.
Someone who dies fighting for the union trying
to abolish slavery is not apologizing for
slavery. They're not even defending it. How
could they possibly be apologizing for it?
This makes no sense under any circumstances,
and I'm having trouble understanding whether
Ben Shapiro doesn't understand history or
doesn't understand or doesn't understand the
definition of apology or maybe some combination
of the three. If the south was apologizing
for slavery, why did they put up endless monuments
to civil war generals who were fighting for
slavery?
That's not usually how apologies work, and
so what you have to understand is that Ben
Shapiro serves a role in right-wing media
and he plays a character in right wing media.
The character he plays is the facts and logic
guy, but really it's just his delivery that
may give people that impression, not the content
of what he says. The role he plays is the
intellectual right-winger who provides rock
solid arguments for right-wingers to feel
good about their incorrect and moral positions,
and that's how you end up believing that single
payer is some form of slavery against doctors
and yet actual slavery is bad, but the u s
has already apologized for it by having a
civil war. Now, there is maybe a silver lining
here. Some of you probably are anticipating
this. He seems to be admitting that the civil
war was about slavery. That's sort of an accomplishment
because very often right-wingers love to say
civil war wasn't about slavery.
It was about states rights, states rights,
of course, to own slaves. But he's actually
saying that it seems to have been about slavery.
And I think that that is actually an accomplishment
in some way, shape, or form, maybe some kind
of progress. I do get scared when people call
into this show and they say, David, I'm on
the left and I love what you do. But I like
to hear strong reason to arguments from the
right. So I listened to Ben Shapiro. That's
scary stuff. And we should all be very scared
when we hear people say that